thank you very much i would like to
thank the organizers for uh
giving this opportunity to learn so much
from my peers and to tell them about my
the works of myself and my colleagues
some of which are listed here
and um to thank the previous speaker for
the wonderful survey of uh
many of the works in this area um
actually as i was sitting here
i was in real time adjusting my slides
to try to uh
optimize for the minimizing the overlap
and
i will cut down on the amount of
introduction
because of the wonderful work we've just
seen
and focus more on the specific things
that
we've been doing in one branch of
research in one application
and the research associated with it so
this will be somewhat biased but more
concrete
and for the sake of concreteness let me
unorthodoxically start
within the application the concrete
application of snarks
i'll describe one of the things that
came out chronologically late but
illustrates
uh the situation where snarks are useful
illustrates a concrete working system
and along the way we'll step back
generalize in light of the
properties that we've grown to
appreciate
and then uh go back to this example and
this motivating application is
zero cash a decentralized anonymous
payment system
uh based on bitcoin in this joint work
with
elements ben sasson chris alessandro
christina garman the mad green ian myers
and it's um
it also brought down to bitcoin we all
appreciate bitcoin a decentralized
digital currency and digital means that
ownership of uh coins is represented
just by
knowledge of some numbers in order to
pay someone you just passed some number
to them
and that immediately trivially raises
the issue of double spending because
if you pass the number to someone and it
convinces them you can pass the same
number to others
and they would be just as convinced
thereby completely ruining the economy
and the way bitcoin codes with this is
using the
blockchain or this distributed ledger
that we heard about
um which simply posts every transaction
we see who paid whom how much and when
and whenever a new transaction is
recorded
uh everybody else knows to avoid
respecting the coin that has just been
spent
the problem there is privacy because
um this blockchain contains all of the
information
as consumers anyone can see our
purchases who we pay whom and how much
at what time
the merchants have their cash flow
exposed to the competitors
anyone can see your balance as you go
down the street paying merchants and
maybe
relieve you of some of it this clearly
is a problem
it's been recognized by many um there is
there is there are some
ways maybe to try to dismiss this like
saying that bitcoin is pseudonymous you
don't really publish your
name in transactions but most users use
a very small number of these pseudonyms
of these addresses
and there are many works showing that
the transaction graph can be analyzed to
the anonymize people
by tracking cash flow and tracking
patterns
another issue is fungibility because
coins
have their history associated with them
through the blockchain
different coins may have different value
depending on that history
which could ruin the uh equivalence of
different coins the
fungibility are underlying the notion of
currency
so we started off creating
uh a decentralized system to avoid
trusting a bank
but with respect to privacy we made just
things much
worse by having uh to trust everyone not
to look at the ledger
and see our private information clearly
not a reasonable way to build the
currency to uh to bind all currencies
so there's been a lot of attention paid
to this many ad hoc solutions
uh the problem with many of them with
most of them
is um that they are um
they rely on some activities some mixing
some mix nets
uh that requires that that are required
essentially to loan their money
to mix your money without of others that
requires conscious effort um
which honest users probably will not
bother going through but criminals will
so we're getting the
the worst of both worlds and
we took a step back and said can we
build a a currency in a way that
is inherently private
and that's indeed what we achieved a new
currency where anyone can pay each other
uh in in in a completely anonymous way
there's still a notion of a blockchain
but instead of recording everything um
there are just some
pseudo-random values and zero-knowledge
proofs recorded that reveal nothing
about the source destination amount
of payment except to those participating
in that particular transaction
um jumping again ahead because
the night of the previous talk we should
be a bit dubious about anything using
snarks so here are some numbers
um we are going to use some proofs they
will be less than 300 bytes long
um it take it will take just a few
milliseconds to verify them
less than a minute to create a
transaction and
there will be some system parameters
that those public parameters or common
reference string
uh that require trusted setup i'll
discuss this later
um they they're less than a gigabyte in
size which is much smaller than the
bitcoin blockchain so that's well within
practical
um and there will be some cryptographic
assumptions um
same we'll be using some pairing based
crypto we'll be using
chat 256 with some standard assumptions
about it and
knowledge of exponent assumptions i'll
look at this as well later
so what is the approach of of zero cache
well the idea is to use snarks to
to rely on proofs and maybe a good
intuitive way to appreciate this is to
uh
is to look at the situation when one
party a sender would like to send some
some amount to a recipient and um they
have the records that prove that they
know who they got the money from that
they haven't spent it
so the sender is convinced that the
information is legit
the recipient of course is not the
bitcoin way of doing it is just send it
over
and the recipient will verify it of
course violence privacy so we wouldn't
do that
instead if we could somehow have a an
accountant come in and apply some
predicate
to this to these financial books
apply some decision algorithm to check
them and then issue some
signature that testing to that fact that
the books are good
well that would be convincing but in the
real world we don't have accountants
accompanying anyone who's trying to make
a payment
but we do have the algorithm that the
accountant would have run
and that's something that we can try
running
virtually in the sender's mind and then
producing a proof that this algorithm
accepted
these financial records as a witness for
this payment generalizing this
uh we have some np statement
we have some np witness there is some np
decision algorithm
and there's a proof and let's see what
properties we need
for this to actually work well we need
the proof to be convincing
and um we will have uh to relax this
notion from proofs
from perfectly sound proofs to
computationally sound proofs or
arguments as we like to call them this
is inevitable due to impossibility
results
we would like them to be non-interactive
because not just
of this transaction but also because
these proofs will later be posted in a
blockchain
so that the recipient of the payment
will later convince others that the coin
that he received was legit
so it has to be posted publicly
therefore it has to be just a string
rather than an
interaction beside non-interactivity we
need to be a proof of knowledge
that's technical condition but crucial
to zerocoin as
as well as many other applications um
that means that
the approver doesn't just not only do
there exist
financial records uh attesting to the
statements but
the approver actually knows them which
is crucial because some of the things in
these records are signatures by others
saying that they actually send the money
to that
to this person and of course that
signatures exist the question is did he
ever receive them
and we want this move to be succinct we
want um
these these strings to be short so we
can put them on the blockchain transmit
them efficiently
and moreover efficiently verifiable yes
you assume it's zero knowledge proof of
knowledge
give me 10 seconds all of this suffice
to convince the verifier efficiently
but we still need to protect the privacy
of the approver and that would be
the zero knowledge property taken
together these things give us a snark
such think non-interactive argument of
knowledge
building up on the snark terminology of
gentry wix
which omits just a knowledge requirement
and
adding the zero knowledge requirement we
get zk snarks
so uh these are many we had a list of
requirements for zika snarks
just zero knowledge well we know that it
exists uh
since uh gmr and uh
we know that non-interactive zero
knowledge exists for all of np using the
common reference string
you can have some setup procedure and
then to convince that x is in
some fixed np language l you can set the
proof uh to the verifier with the
nice zero knowledge and soundness
properties you can even make
a non-interactive zero launch proofs of
knowledge um
and they're actually pretty efficient
proto non-interactive zero knowledge
protocols for some specific languages
with
uh that are essentially simple algebraic
statements that
play nicely with the crypto but what
about general statements that don't have
the right algebraic form
and the question is can we support them
in general
can we have succinct non-interactive
zero knowledge
of knowledge for all of np
and by succinctness just to make things
concrete if we think about the statement
as executed by turing machine
m running forty steps on some input x
that's not too long
using weakness w then succinctly it
means that the
proofs are short constant after the
security parameter
and verification depends just on the
input size
if we had this we could do many
wonderful things we could outsource
computation
right delegate it one of those big
buzzwords so we could send information
off to the cloud
with instructions on what to do the the
cloud would come back
a year later with uh with a claim that
they know the results
and uh well if we could create a proof
that the convinces the verifier that the
result is
result is correct then we wouldn't have
to trust the integrity of the cloud we
could just send it to the cheapest
bidder
and still trust the result efficiently
verify it um
so some of you may have seen our demo on
stage uh
the crypto 13 where we had easy to
solve a traveling session problem for us
send us a qr code with the result and we
verified it
in a few seconds on stage
the proof was a few hundred bytes the
computation was done out there on the
cloud
so this is conceptually very appealing
and as you know by now
the general case is not quite
economically appealing yet
if you want additionally big thinking
cloudy motivations then
the information technology supply chain
if you're applying for grants this is a
good one
um so the problem is that everybody's
buying hardware from the cheapest bidder
and
uh if and they're trusting the results
of that and even the u.s military is
finding itself deploying
to iraq and afghanistan computers that
turn out to be
counterfeit and could at least
potentially contain malicious hardware
and malfunction at the critical moment
we actually know that chinese political
scientists uh
say that they shouldn't bother building
spaceship sorry
carrier ships uh when they could just
make sure that uh the
adversary's carrier ships malfunction at
the right time
so as you can see uh snarks are well
justified and
the question is how do we how do we
construct them
well we just heard a lot about it and uh
there's been
um a an amazing progress in
a few years we've actually known for a
while that uh
short uh non-interactive proofs and zero
knowledge proofs are possible
starting with uh kilian mikali and the
extension by valiant um those were based
on full-blown pcps
with merkle trees on top and uh random
accent
and the random oracle to uh navigate the
merkle tree
and that's a very beautiful feasibility
result
and we actually have an ongoing project
to implement this
we have not yet published but working in
our lab full pcp is a
proving simple statements the overheads
are very large but
it's uh it's not galactic it's something
that we can run experiments for
yes
what are the bottlenecks for short pcps
and why do the linear pcps currently
have
smaller coefficients smaller constants
so um let me answer that in a second
um go is still staying with the pc with
the full-blown pcp track
um do we even have a good understanding
of
what exactly is needed here random
oracles
well uh they're not
they clearly say that we don't
understand everything and
there is a tita characterization uh we
know that uh
uh snarks exist if and only if there
exists extractable collision resistant
hashes
there are constructions both ways um
and uh extractable collision resistant
hashes are
basically crhs with the extra property
that uh
if you output an element in the uh range
of the of that function a digest of
something
then you actually know that something so
it's a non-facial
non-falsifiable uh knowledge type
assumption
and uh in this paper we give a bunch of
candidates including knowledge of
exponents and also others closer in
spirit to lwe
um i encourage you to cryptanalyze these
assumptions little is known about them
the problem is these are still based on
pcps and
the new results
the newer results on the left side of
the slide
take a different approach based on
linear pcps
and this paper of bc iop uh
gives a very nice characterization of
many of these results in this framework
of linear pcps
they don't originally phrase it this way
but i think it's conceptually the right
way
the intuition for why the proofs are
more efficient is that we shift uh
some of the weight from the
combinatorics to the crypto
uh if you look at the full pcps they
spend
a lot of resources to make sure that
there are certain
there's a certain linear structure in
the between the elements of the proofs
and using uh the knowledge of exponent
assumption we kind of get this for free
we know that certain things can only
have be constructed by linear
manipulations
and therefore many of the checks
can be escaped it's a very high level
so there are many protocols here and
many implementations
many of these are based on the ggpr
protocol preceded by protocols of growth
and litmo that set up the stage
and we can uh there are many ways to to
slice this pro
this uh this progress let me just focus
on one of them due to time constraints
and this is if we focus on snacks for
general c programs
so well i perhaps more
uh theoretically for ram machines but
uh to make it concrete for potential
users let's go for the full things
c programs take a sec program and
compile it into a version
that not only produces the outputs but
also produces a proof that the output
was correct
so we know since kilian and mikali that
this is
in principle feasible you can produce a
proof for a single computation
we've also learned that it's possible to
do is for ongoing computation using
proof caring data
where proofs
concatenate goes back to valiant and
extended by
kiaza myself we
have um using the uh
gdpr and the pghr protocol
and improvements their own we greatly
improved feasibility
and the efficiency of verification
leading up to actually working
prototypes for
small c programs running for a short
amount of time
then this can be extended by allowing
nec programs using
universality basically having a
universal
processor that is
a phenomenon architecture it gets its
input
it's get its program as an input and
runs it and that means um
you can do the common you can construct
that setup
parameter once and then support any
program
um and also um
uh you can uh using uh these
these tricks of proof composition extend
the proof step by step therefore thereby
making things scalable and supporting
programs running arbitrarily long uh
with
uh just a essentially multiplicative
constant overhead
in both time and memory so you can think
about it as
a processor that just runs a program in
a secure way but issuing proofs
and it has a
constant resources as a function of the
security parameter
and the original program size it does
not grow with the length of the
computation
and um
and of course the consumption of the
memory consumption of the original
program not just this size
but
this this processor has a well defined
hertz rating
right now it's in uh it's measured in uh
the deci hertz which is kind of
too slow for practice but at least it's
well defined unlike previous
constructions where
the size of the processor would blow up
as it computes
um now
the the big issue here is still the
proving overhead that's the the main
challenge for practicality
and that's what currently limits
applications uh
like uh outsourcing to the cloud
whole new branch is doing things uh in a
tighter way
by program analysis and non-generic
reductions
we've just heard about in the previous
talks this is one of the things that i
cut out things like gepetto buffet
they have much tighter reductions
quantitatively but
a cost in uh universality in uh
supporting random accesses and a general
control flow
except for buffet where it does support
it but with a fallback to a performance
that's
comparable to uh to these systems
and one of this is the one that we
actually use in zero cache
which we'll get back to in a sec yes
um so uh that refers to uh
continuing the computation uh imagine
that you have a data center full of
of machines none of which are trusted
you would like the first machine to
produce an output and
along with the proof of it and the next
machine would consume that work on it
and produce a new output with a new
proof and you
maintain the invariant that every value
flowing in your data center
would it has the the proof associated
with it
all of these are publicly verifiable why
are not why don't you get any hopes
in all of them then you can if you just
concatenate the proofs and all of the
values needed to check the proofs
the instances uh but if he wants a
sickness if you want to check only the
last value
then you need something more
yes what would you mean
i thought michael just gave us okay he
said
buffet support nac program so it is
universal right so that's a
qualification i gave the
uh in order to support universality
you need to uh uh
universal i mean i'd love it if it were
but it's not what what he means by
universality is the same circuit
can actually verify multiple different
programs that's not what's going on
about that
you're talking about the recursive
composition no no he's talking about
representing a processor as a circuit
and then once he's representing a
processor as a circuit he can for any
computation
yeah but that's not an efficient
approach you just want to be able
to that's exactly the claim yes we the
tightest approach are
not universal and in order to exploit
the tightness you give up on the
general random accesses and the general
control flow
universality just means you want to be
able to do any program it doesn't mean
that you actually have to go through our
universes because there are ways that
you can optimize that
and not everything has to go through the
universal circuit
right yes
okay so uh to build such a system for
general c
programs you have to go through quite a
stack of reductions we have the
underlying snack proven verifier
uh they get some input and weakness or
auxiliary input they produce
the approval produces an output and a
proof
but these are for
some algebraic construct and if you
uh start with the c program
uh then uh you need to go through a
series of reductions uh one five but we
have a couple of papers
explaining and proving the soundness of
these reductions going from c programs
in our case to support universality
through some
specialized a cp architecture a risk
machine we call tinyram
then we lay that out as
a constraints the dysfunction problem
that fixes the topology
and assign that to algebraic variables
and all of this
is fairly expensive and it does
contribute
about two orders of magnitude overhead
as a rule of thumb compared to tighter
approaches
for zero cash to avoid this we actually
trade our things in a much much tighter
way
um and uh let me tell you about this
how are we doing on time okay are you
going to give some
concrete performance numbers do you have
confidence numbers for the recursive
competition
recursively composed um
i can give this now uh the uh
if you do uh the a fully
universal version with scalability with
the recursive composition
um that gives us a
that cpu in the on the order of a deci
hertz that is about
it is a cycle of the cpu advancing it
and producing a proof takes about 10
seconds
and that's for an a that's without a
multi-threading or gpu acceleration
or anything of the sorts that would be
naturally applied if you really put your
mind to it
so it shows that it's doable but not yet
appealing
yes
let's take this offline i have some
additional numbers for trade-offs
okay so for zero cash um let's see how
things are instantiated to get a feel
for what you do if you actually wanted
to
get a practical application nowadays
without going through all the extra
extra levels of obstruction and
reduction
so um let me go
take you through a series three series
of uh toy examples
leading up to uh the full scheme um
the most basic way to build anonymous
cache not very well
is uh just to have a bunch of serial
numbers out there and in order to create
a new coin
you prove that you're eligible to it for
example that you've just burned a
bitcoin
and that makes you eligible to serial
number all the serial numbers are posted
and in order to spend the coin you just
say
okay i'm using a coin to give you a
serial number
makes sense except no privacy whatsoever
anyone can link the spending event to
the minting event
to solve this there's a very elegant
approach of sander and tashma
preceding decentralized currencies and
the idea is to use a commitment scheme
where every coin has several values
associated with it
a serial number a commitment to the
serial number using some randomness
using the hiding and binding commitment
function and to mean you say that you
spend a bitcoin to create
a coin whose commitment is cm only you
know the serial number
so brown is private uh blue is public in
the ledger
and all these commitments are public and
now well to spend the coin you can just
open the commitment right you say okay i
spent the coin with the serial number
and uh here is the corresponding
commitment and the randomness to link
the two and anyone can verify that the
serial number
is unique and matches the commitment
that's not private either because again
you expose the commitment that you
posted earlier so mint can spending can
be linked
so the idea of sander and tashma is to
you is
to use your knowledge proofs as follows
we build a nice big merkle tree using a
crh on top of all the commitments
and then we prove that uh well
when we spend a coin with a given serial
number we proved that
we know the coin randomness and the
commitment
that's in the tree such that these two
match the cm
but we don't tell which one so uh
all of this is done using a zero
knowledge proof and
it requires to be convincing a proof or
an argument
uh it needs to be non-interactive so
people can broadcast that
it needs to be zero knowledge so nothing
is leaked about the cm that could allow
linkability to the minting
it should be proof of knowledge and uh
it should be succinct
so zk snarks okay so
we can already do a very basic scheme
using zk snarks
instead to instantiate it to instantiate
my standards
but once we do that well we can use the
np power of zk snarks
to get additional functionality that was
not achieved by any of the prior
attempts at anonymity for bitcoin
for example you can add variable
denominations coin with different values
by adding an an extra commitment um
and go over this very quickly just to
give a feel i know you won't have time
to verify the details but
uh to mint you you say that you spend v
bitcoins to create a commitment and
you actually reveal the value it's
public and you also reveal the
randomness for an auto commit but
there's another extra commit
down there that you do not reveal and to
spend you actually reveal everything and
show that it's consistent
um under protected under zero knowledge
we can add direct anonymous payments
supporting payments addressed to people
with some permanent addresses without
revealing where the payment is going
um so that requires some algorithm to
create an address pair
and then the coin structure becomes much
more complicated now there's couple of
commitments some prf
to derive the serial number from the
secret key and
uh the public is involved in creating
the commitment
it's pretty tricky and uh well you can
set things up so that uh meeting and
spending are analogous to above
basically to uh use up a coin you
created your knowledge proof that the
values
you have are consistent with the
commitment we're sorry with some
commitment
in the past and you reveal the serial
number so everybody make sure you know
double spending
and the sender can decrypt
using a secret key and thereby
get all of the values needed for them to
use up that coin
now all of these and many more details
are elegantly summarized in what we call
a poor transaction
and um if you can think about the poor
transaction as a primitive for direct
anonymous payments
that generalizes sending payments um
merging
coins uh making change by splitting
coins
uh providing transaction transaction
fees uh
and many other things it gets it
consumes old coins
it creates new coins it gets a uh
instructions on what is the value and
destination of the new coins
and it outputs uh things that will be uh
put in
the ledger that consume the old coins
create the new coins and
include the proof that the old coins
were indeed valid
and that crucially the monetary
invariant was preserved the total value
of the new coins equals that of the old
coins
all of this is the np statement
what's verified by that virtual
accountant
um and that's what you find in the
ledger so uh this np statement is
tailored to zerocoin and we implemented
it in the underlying language of qaps
following uh gdpr pghr and
our improvements on them and you can
actually see what a transaction looks
like
um you can see the current mercury rules
serial numbers of the consume coin
commitments
um ciphertext addressed to the recipient
so you can get the ownership on the
coins
a bunch of other things dealing with
nominability i won't get into that
and the zero knowledge proof which is
you know small enough to fit on the
slide
now this is properly formalized in a
primitive decentralized anonymous
payment system
using uh algorithms to set up the
parameters create addresses and so on
and there are security notions
distinguishability based i'm very
optimistic about the new
um a simulation based alternatives that
elaine presented
these are the ones we used you can see
the details in the paper
there's a full walking prototype uh i
mentioned the numbers earlier and we
actually simulated all of this on the
bitcoin
scale economy uh we replayed uh bitcoin
transactions
uh on ec2 and it kept it could keep
up uh with the uh rate of transactions
on bitcoin
which uh is not trivial and could not be
said for some
previous constructions that had even
less functionality
uh trusted setup is a big issue here um
the trusted setup essentially creates a
template for what the correct
construction looks like and the template
is about a gigabyte
in size if that setup is corrupted uh
then the soundness fails fortunately
privacy still holds
and we have an npc protocol to address
that
we can set up a ceremony with end
players
suffices just one of them is honest for
the currency to be sound
it's not as good as eliminating it but i
think in practice it's close to
satisfying
um so taking a step back let me mention
some open problems
uh for snacks in general and for zero
cash in particular
one is uh reducing the proving time
right now it takes less than a minute
say 47 seconds on my desktop
to create a transaction it's okay
comparable to the 10 minute
blockchain operator rate update rate but
we could hope for better and certainly
for other applications we need much
better
pre-processing is a big issues uh it
could be achieved either by
better pcps that take us back to the uh
to those constructions that do not have
trusted setup
or maybe some completely other approach
approaches i think it's a fascinating
problem
we don't know much in the way of
impossibility and so far and
i think the we've only started to be to
explore the landscape
um more applications um
don't you need trusted setup for zero
knowledge so you need like a common
reference trend for zero knowledge
uh that's a good question i'm not sure
um but it's interesting even without
your knowledge
um for um we're looking for more
applications in particular ones where we
have very tight reductions
uh creating small np statements that can
be nicely expressed in the underlying
language of the snark
and the fascinating pl work that's uh
that's begun
doing this in an automated way many
interesting challenges there on the pl
and optimization perspectives
and on the theory side
can we get base things on more
assumptions
we know that the general pcp based
snarks can be done on general ecrh's and
uh
knowledge of exponent gives us just one
family what about the others
um can we can we build snarks
on the lwe star assumptions can we build
snarks that are sound in the presence of
quantum computers
so since time is out let me just give
three urls for our work on snarks in
general
for works on zero cache in particular
and our source code for lip snark that
includes implementations of most of what
you've seen
thank you